it's the school holiday symbol in a time
when many people of Turkish origin visit
relatives and friends in Turkey is
Germany's new travel advisor reason for
them not to travel to Turkey this year I
went to one of the oldest Turkish travel
agents in Berlin to find out I must say
all the flights to Turkey and other
places - I mean Istanbul and all other
places are almost booked out - the
beginning of August said there are
hardly any seats the travel agents have
their hands full
let's ask people on the street I will
travel to Turkey like every year I only
felt in danger that once on the day of
the coup attempt last year I was stuck
at the airport there no one throws
anyone who's against him in jail and he
would throw me in jail too that's why
I'm not going this year
I think the politics in Turkey right now
are wrong no not this year I've just
come back from Spain and because of
what's going on in Turkey right now I'm
just not going to go there most of the
people of Turkish origin that I talked
to didn't know about the travel warning
that the German government issued for
Turkey still some of them already
decided not to spend this year summer
holidays as usual in Turkey